Haley I was getting prez's per welcome
to plug-and-play
and suggested me this game he said it's
weird I'm all about that weird but that
I'm so sorry plug and play baby
alright the fingers are going to connect
these are very long fingers I hope they
are fingers I don't hope their fingers
they might be carrots please be carrots
there we go you touched that's awkward
it's always awkward when you know
oh and playing go that way say no all
right [ __ ] it then go that way no that
way
all right just your cue then oh god no
no no no don't do it
dah they did it and what what is what is
what is Scout what is going on no no
Gary Gary nope I know that's that's
tempting ace I know it's tempting I know
it's coming for you but run run Jerry no
Jerry no oh
alright sarin uninstall never play this
game again button the thing nothing in
life will ever be the same after this
you're missing your mitt you're missed
Oh No let it go let it go oh please make
it stop
just biggest it dangles so vividly in
the light oh hello
the end
[Music]
[Laughter]
someone was horny as [ __ ] and bored as
[ __ ]
and they made this game okay alright
suggest me some more weird games in the
comments leave a like if you enjoyed
this one and yeah I'm gonna go
reconsider my life alright press thank
you for watching and as always stay
awesome bros
[Music]